Sometimes, the sheer amount of quality TV
out there means that even the best shows aren't
safe from the chopping block — take NBC's
"Manifest," for example.
The supernatural drama tells the story of
the people aboard Montego Air Flight 828,
which somehow lands five and a half years
in the future.
The show's intriguing concept and exciting
plot have made it a fan favorite and, as a
result, "Manifest" has been a reliable workhorse
and one of the network's most popular shows
of its kind.
Unfortunately, the world of small-screen entertainment
is a volatile place, and even these considerable
accolades weren't enough to keep "Manifest"
afloat.
Recent news indicates that NBC has opted against
greenlighting "Manifest" Season 4, and as
such, the show is pretty much history.
"No, no, no…"
This means there's a very real chance that
fans will never find out exactly what happened
to the people aboard the fateful flight — which
is all the more frustrating when you consider
that the ending of Season 3 added a seemingly
never-ending line of cliffhangers to the already
impressive mountain of mysteries.
Despite this, the show's fate appears to have
been sealed, so for now, there's only one
real mystery that needs to be solved: Why
on Earth was "Manifest" canceled in the first
place?
"It makes no sense."
Now, if you think that the cancellation news
came as a bit of a surprise to fans, "Manifest"
creator Jeff Rake certainly agrees.
After the hammer dropped, he tweeted...
"My dear Manifesters, I'm devastated by NBC's
decision to cancel us.
That we've been shut down in the middle is
a gut punch to say the least.
Hoping to find a new home.
You the fans deserve an ending to your story.
Thanks for the love shown to me, cast, and
crew."
He also included the hashtag "savemanifest,"
which might very well see a fair amount of
use in the future.
The news of the show's grim fate arrived on
June 14, and as Deadline reported, the die
was cast shortly before the actors' options
expired.
This, of course, means that "Manifest" only
got halfway through its planned six-season
arc.
"But why?"
As for why anyone could even consider canceling
a seemingly successful show like "Manifest"
in the first place, the answer is still up
in the air.
However, TV Series Finale has noted that the
show's third season didn't manage to attract
quite as many viewers as the previous two,
to the point that its ratings dropped 31 percent
in the 18 to 49 demographic.
Still, considering that "Manifest" was nevertheless
quite popular, the decision not to renew it
couldn't have been an easy one — which could
explain why the network waited until the last
moments to pull the plug.
Though "Manifest" is down for now, there's
a decent chance that it's not out.
Obviously, the show has no shortage of plot
left — and, as Deadline notes, creator Jeff
Rake has made it clear that he'd still like
to wrap up the remaining three seasons.
Likewise, Warner Bros. TV is reportedly putting
out feelers to see if the show can be rescued.
Even if the series ends up finding a new home,
there may still be some wrinkles in the plan,
since it appears that the options of the cast
of "Manifest" have expired.
So, regardless of what happens, a potential
return would likely have plenty of hurdles
to clear, and even a best-case scenario might
mean that fans will have to wait for quite
some time before new episodes arrive.
Then again, fan-favorite shows of a sufficiently
high profile have been rescued from the scrap
heap before.
The beloved sci-fi show "The Expanse" is heading
toward Season 6, because Amazon Prime picked
it up after Syfy dropped it before its fourth
season.
NBC itself rescued the popular police sitcom
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine" in the wake of Fox cancelling
it.
Hopefully, some platform or network will extend
the same courtesy to "Manifest" and all of
its unsolved mysteries.
Luckily for fans, "Manifest" is no lemon,
and might hold plenty of allure for the right
buyer.
In fact, before the show got the ax, it was
trending on Netflix.
Time will tell if this means that the streaming
platform is interested in further seasons
of the show, but it may not be outside the
realm of possibility.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.